Lo inmediato, lo efímero parece dominar nuestras vidas,
nuestra economía y nuestra política.
Es tan fácil enfrascarnos en la cantidad de pasos que dimos hoy
o en el último tweet de alguna figura prominente.
Para las empresas, es fácil dejarse llevar por el beneficio inmediato
y dejar de lado cosas que son buenas para el futuro.
Y a los Gobiernos les resulta muy fácil quedarse de brazos cruzados
mientras se agotan los recursos marítimos y agropecuarios,
en lugar de preservarlos para alimentar a futuras generaciones.
Tengo la impresión de que, a este ritmo,
es difícil que nuestra generación pase a la historia como un buen ancestro.
Pensándolo bien, nuestra especie evolucionó para pensar a futuro,
para estudiar las estrellas,
soñar con la vida después de la muerte,
sembrar semillas para cosechar después.
Para algunos científicos, este superpoder de "viajar mentalmente por el tiempo",
es la causa de prácticamente todo lo que llamamos civilización humana.
Desde la agricultura, pasando por la Carta Magna
y hasta hasta Internet:
todo fue concebido por la mente humana.
Pero, seamos realistas,
si miramos a nuestro alrededor hoy en día
parece que no estamos usando este superpoder mucho que digamos.
La pregunta obvia es: ¿por qué no?
El error está en el diseño
de nuestras comunidades, empresas e instituciones.
Están diseñadas de forma tal que reducen con nuestra visión a futuro.
Quiero hablarles
de los tres principales errores que creo que estamos cometiendo.
El primer error es lo que medimos.
Los resultados trimestrales de una empresa
o el valor de sus acciones a corto plazo
muchas veces no son un buen indicador
de que vaya a aumentar su cuota de mercado
o de que vaya a ser innovadora a largo plazo.
Obsesionarnos con los resultados de los exámenes escolares
no es necesariamente lo mejor para la educación y la curiosidad
de los niños a largo plazo.
No estamos midiendo lo que es realmente importante para el futuro.
El segundo error que cometemos y nos limita la visión a futuro
es lo que recompensamos.
Cuando celebramos a un político o a un empresario
por el desastre que acaba de arreglar
o el anuncio que acaba de hacer,
no estamos motivando a ese líder
a que invierta en prevenir esos desastres en primer lugar,
o a que invierta en el futuro,
ya sea protegiendo comunidades en riesgo de inundación,
luchando contra la desigualdad
o haciendo inversiones en investigación y educación.
El tercer error que reduce nuestra visión a futuro
es lo que no somos capaces de imaginar.
Cuando pensamos en el futuro,
en general, tratamos de predecir exactamente lo que va a suceder,
ya sea con horóscopos o algoritmos.
pero pasamos mucho menos tiempo imaginando todas las posibilidades del futuro.
Cuando estalló la crisis del ébola en África occidental en 2014,
los organismos públicos en todo el mundo contaban con señales de alerta temprana
y herramientas de predicción que mostraban
cómo podría llegar a propagarse el virus.
Pero no se dieron cuenta de que lo haría,
no intervinieron a tiempo
y la epidemia avanzó hasta matar 11 000 personas.
Cuando aquellos que tienen amplios recursos y buenos pronósticos
no se preparan para lidiar con huracanes devastadores,
es porque, muchas veces, no son capaces de imaginar
lo peligrosos que pueden llegar a ser.
Ahora bien, estos errores,
por más deprimentes que suenen,
no son inevitables.
En realidad, son todos evitables.
Para tomar mejores decisiones, necesitamos herramientas
que nos ayuden a ver el futuro y a pensar por adelantado.
Piensen en los telescopios
que usaban los marineros de antaño cuando avistaban el horizonte.
Solo que, en lugar de mirar a la distancia en el océano,
estas herramientas miran en el tiempo hacia el futuro.
Quiero hablarles de algunas herramientas
que he encontrado en mis investigaciones
y creo que pueden ayudarnos con nuestra visión a futuro.
La primera herramienta que quiero compartir
es algo así como apostar a largo plazo pero con los resultados ahora.
Este es Wes Jackson, un agricultor con quien me encontré en Kansas.
Jackson sabe
que la mayoría de los métodos de cultivo utilizados hoy en día en todo el mundo
deterioran la capa fértil de la tierra
que necesitamos para alimentar a las generaciones futuras.
Junto con un grupo de científicos
cultivaron una variedad de grano perenne
con raíces profundas que sujetan la capa fértil
previniendo así la erosión y protegiendo las futuras cosechas.
Pero también sabían
que para incentivar a los agricultores a cultivar estos granos en el corto plazo
debían aumentar el rendimiento anual
y encontrar empresas dispuestas a hacer cereales y cerveza con ellos
para que los agricultores pudieran ver hoy el beneficio de algo bueno para el futuro.
Se ha demostrado que la estrategia funciona.
De hecho, la usó George Washington Carver
en el sur de los EE. UU. luego de la guerra civil
a principios del siglo XX.
Muchos habrán oído hablar de los 300 usos para el maní de Carver,
los productos y recetas que él inventó
y tanta popularidad le dieron al maní.
Pero no todos saben por qué lo hizo.
Estaba tratando de ayudar a los pobres agricultores en Alabama,
porque sus cosechas de algodón perdían rendimiento
y él sabía que, si plantaban maní, el suelo se recuperaría
y el rendimiento del algodón mejoraría en los años subsiguientes.
Pero también sabía que necesitaban un ingreso en el corto plazo.
Hablemos ahora de otra herramienta para la visión de futuro.
Esta se trata de mantener vivo el recuerdo del pasado
para ayudarnos a imaginar el futuro.
Fui a Fukushima, Japón,
para el sexto aniversario del desastre nuclear
que ocurrió luego del terremoto y del tsunami en Tohoku en 2011.
Durante mi estadía me enteré de la central nuclear de Onagawa,
que estaba aún más cerca del epicentro del terremoto
que la infame Fukushima Daiichi, que todos conocemos.
En Onagawa, la gente huyó de la ciudad
para refugiarse en la central nuclear.
Era así de seguro.
Quedó a salvo del tsunami.
Fue la previsión de un solo ingeniero,
Yanosuke Hirai,
que lo hizo posible.
En los años 60
él abogó para que la planta se construyera más lejos de la costa,
en un punto más elevado y con una escollera más alta.
Conocía la historia del santuario en su ciudad natal,
que se había inundado en el año 869 como consecuencia de un tsunami.
Su conocimiento de la historia
le permitió imaginar lo que otros no podían.
OK, una herramienta más para la visión a futuro.
Esta se trata de crear reliquias compartidas.
Estos pescadores de langosta en la costa del Pacífico en México,
son los que me enseñaron esto.
Han estado protegiendo esta cosecha de langosta
durante casi un siglo,
y lo han conseguido porque lo ven como un recurso compartido
que pasa a las manos de sus hijos y nietos.
Miden cuidadosamente lo que pescan
para asegurarse de agotar la langosta en el océano.
En América del Norte, hay más de 30 pesquerías
que están haciendo algo similar a esto.
Están implementando cuotas de captura
que motivan a los pescadores,
no solo a capturar lo que puedan hoy,
sino también a pensar en el futuro del océano.
Hay muchas más herramientas para la visión a futuro
que me encantaría compartir
y que son muy variadas:
inversionistas que ven más allá del valor de las acciones a corto plazo,
países que han liberado sus elecciones
de los intereses inmediatos de quienes financian la campaña.
Vamos a necesitar tantas herramientas como podamos conseguir
si queremos repensar lo que medimos,
cambiar lo que recompensamos
y ser lo suficientemente valientes como para imaginar lo que viene.
Todo esto no siempre será fácil, como se imaginarán.
Algunas de estas herramientas las podemos adoptar en nuestras vidas,
otras las tendremos que trabajar con las empresas y las comunidades,
y otras son para trabajar en sociedad.
Vale la pena el esfuerzo por el futuro.
My propia fuente de inspiración para esto es ese instrumento que les mostré.
Se llama "dilruba",
y fue hecho a medida para mi bisabuelo.
Él fue un músico y crítico muy conocido en la India
a principios del siglo XX.
Mi bisabuelo tuvo la previsión de proteger este instrumento
en una época cuando mi bisabuela estaba empeñando todas sus pertenencias,
pero eso es otra historia.
Lo protegió dándoselo a la próxima generación:
se lo dio a mi abuela,
y ella me lo dio a mí.
La primera vez que escuché el sonido de este instrumento,
me pareció muy evocador.
Era como escuchar a un vagabundo en la niebla de los Himalayas.
Era como oír una voz del pasado.
(Música)
(Fin de música)
Ese es mi amigo Simran Singh tocando el dilruba.
Cuando lo toco yo, suena como si estuvieran matando a un gato,
así que de nada.
(Risas)
Este instrumento hoy está en mi casa,
pero no me pertenece a mí.
Mi rol es conducirlo a través del tiempo,
y eso me parece más significativo que ser simplemente su dueña hoy.
Este instrumento me posiciona como descendiente y como ancestro.
Me hace sentir parte de una historia que es más grande que la mía.
Y esta, a mi entender,
es la forma más poderosa que tenemos de recuperar la visión a futuro:
vernos como los buenos ancestros que queremos ser.
ancestros no solo de nuestros hijos,
sino de toda la humanidad.
Sea cual fuere su reliquia,
grande o pequeña,
protéjanla,
y sepan que su música puede resonar por generaciones.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)